[Applause]
[Music]
it's the middle of summer the perfect
time to take a vacation with this week's
games you can slip away to the Middle
Ages wrestling rings and even a
communist nation maybe think twice about
that last one but do be sure to
subscribe to get new releases delivered
to you every Sunday if you've been
craving a new Final Fantasy experience
you'll get it with the zodiac age this
is a remaster of Final Fantasy 12
international job system version which
released a full decade ago it included
extra job boards corresponding to the
zodiac symbols new game plus and minus
options and the ability to speed up
gameplay this fresh ps4 version also
adds trophy support a newly arranged
soundtrack and the usual graphical and
technical improvements if you want a
closer look at one of the most under the
radar Final Fantasy games out there you
can check out tons of gameplay and
interviews with the devs over on
GameSpot otherwise you can start your
adventure on Tuesday July 11 but before
you fight monsters in aivalis why not
throw down in the squared circle fire
pro wrestling world is meant as a return
to form for the storied wrestling game
after a very disappointing button masher
on Xbox Live Arcade world uses the
strategic timing based wrestling
gameplay for death matches steel cage
matches and for the first time online
multiplayer letting up to four wrestlers
throw down it's coming to steam early
access on Monday July 10th with full PC
and ps4 releases planned for the future
fingers crossed someone makes a custom
character for the best pro wrestler ever
oh let's move from the wrestling ring to
the Crips iron cryptical is a medieval
twin-stick shooter full of ghouls and
ghosts to smash through as you try to
rescue the princess of Kryptonian and
gather the Kings lost treasures up to
four Knights can band together in local
co-op to descend through the crypts
gather loot
level up and learn new magical abilities
you can start your run on July 11th on
ps4 then the following day on Xbox one
and PC black the fall is about as far as
you can get from the Middle Ages this is
a dark adventure game about an old
machinist and his robot companion is
scaping from a communist regime yeah the
black in the games title really does
match the tone inspired by real-world
events you'll have to use the designator
tool to solve puzzles and manipulate
objects as you make your escape you can
make a break for it on ps4 Xbox one and
PC on the 11th and now for something
completely different again day Mambo is
a one-button brawler and yes that means
you have just one input for charging up
and launching yourself across the screen
your goal is to knock your friends out
of the arena though you can also team up
with those friends for a co-op mode
against some space invaders look-alikes
ps4 Xbox one and PC versions of day
Mambo are in the works but it's coming
first to Nintendo's switch on the 13th
and those are the big games we'll be
playing this week as always remember
that release dates are based on retailer
listings and are subject to change
thanks for watching guys and I'll be
back with more games next week